good morning Jonah's Monday October 16th
Columbus Day it's a holiday I'm hoping
that that in addition to several other
factors well then than me not having to
do a punishment other factors include
the fact that it is indeed still today
here in Montana though it is not on the
East Coast the fact that my computer
crashed like 18 times while I was making
this video and I really wasn't gonna
have it done on time but equipment
malfunction is the real reason so I
think we all have certain goals that
when we achieve them it's sort of
world-changing life-changing experience
and nothing is ever the same again I
achieve two of those goals recently the
first was that I moved in to my own
purchased I own this house I wanted to
show you guys all around this house and
so I decided to do that by doing my
second world-changing life-changing goal
that I have been wanting to do for my
entire life for the past couple years so
I'm going to show you my house while
doing a Numa Numa dance if you don't
know what that means it's okay you'll
probably enjoy it anyway
[Music]
my
hi doc see they're all better
[Music]
yeah
that's beep she's avoiding me - nobody
[Music]
daddy
Hey
by a
[Music]
study
a vessel set spoon Jesse I Love You Man
[Music]
very cheese Indiana show because Oh
she's avoiding that said
Jeremy
a study Bay
[Music]
she
Oh
[Music]
so if you want or don't want me to be
punished please leave a comment below
saying your preference I have to eat now
because I haven't eaten anything it's
like midnight John I'll see you tomorrow